- People wanna understand Russia.
So it's probably
time we brought that up.
So the Internet Research Agency,
a Kremlin-linked social
media manipulation entity,
actually began its
disinformation campaigns
in late 2014.
It used all social
networks to grow audiences,
every single one of them.
Something just came out today that,
you know it's sort of like
this NSFW kind of thing,
but apparently they made
like some porn also,
like they were everywhere, everywhere.
And as deep fakes become more prevalent
I think we can continue to,
deep fakes are manipulated videos,
so as the content that
is manipulatable changes,
the adversary grabs on to
the most bleeding-edge thing,
recognizing that that's
where the least defense is,
that those fronts are
really not well defended
and not well monitored.
So Russia really went hard on Facebook,
and so these are some of the, I think,
God, there are dozens of
pages, I think, I'm sorry,
I'm a little brain-dead
on my facts right now,
47 or 67, but they had
a lot of these pages,
this is just a handful of them.
They, you can kind of,
you can probably gauge
what they are based on the names,
and so what I wanna call
attention to here is Blacktivist,
so this was a Black Lives Matter page,
but it was just a little
bit more extreme, right?
Defend the 2nd, gun rights,
little bit more extreme.
LGBT United was a pro-LGBT family page,
the person writing it was a lesbian
and it was very pro-gay families,
but it was just a little bit provocative.
And actually what they were doing
was they were serving the content
to people who were likely
to be opposed to it.
So the pages, you know,
they have relatively
normal-sounding names,
if you've been on Facebook
I'm sure you've seen pages
with names very similar,
I'm sure you've seen content
that looks exactly like this,
widely shared.
So here are two of the
memes, Army of Jesus
and Secured Borders, you'll notice,
they gave me this handy thing,
I don't know if it's actually on but,
yeah, there ya go.
So you'll notice that they
actually brand their content,
and that's because they're
trying to look like
you know, a community page
or a citizen journalist page,
or an activist page.
So all of the content
that these pages produced
had these marks which it
actually made it quite convenient
for tracking them across the internet.
But there's a couple of things
that I wanna just call attention to here,
this is memetic propaganda,
and we'll go into memes in a minute,
but one thing that's
really interesting to note
is the call to action, "Like
if you want Jesus to win."
So when you like the content
you're communicating back
to the social platform
something about yourself,
which makes it easier for them
to reach you in the future.
You've just given a signal
that you are receptive
to this kind of content.
If I'm running ads and
I have an ads budget,
I'm gonna wanna spend as
little money as possible,
so I'm gonna wanna serve ads to people
who've already engaged with my content,
or done something to indicate to me
that they like what I have to serve.
And that's because that's
how I find my true believers,
and as I said a propagandist
needs an audience,
so that's how I'm gonna
continue to proselytize
to the most receptive.
Similarly if you like "If
you want Jesus to win,"
Facebook will transmit that like
to some percentage of the
people in your broader network,
who it thinks will also
be receptive to this,
and so that's how we find
ourselves in a position
where what you do and what you share
directly impacts your friends,
and how information spreads virally
through small, vulnerable communities.
IRL, they ran events, they
literally had event pages.
There was one notable instance in Texas
where there was a pro-Muslim page
and a pro-Texas secessionist page.
They set up events, rallies,
on the same day in the same place,
trying to get the people
into the same place
at the same time, and
they got a riot out of it.
And these are people who
are sitting in Russia,
not even in the US,
getting two groups of
Americans to literally show up
and have a fight in the streets in Texas.
So disinformation, in
order to be effective,
must be 90% accurate,
and this is where the studies
of human psychology come in
with propaganda,
the fact that the content
that they're producing
looked plausibly American.
When I showed you those memes,
the first thing you think
isn't Russian troll in
Siberia, maybe now it is,
but two years ago it
most definitely wasn't.
And so that's where we think
they're producing content
that is just, you know
it is so true looking,
it's just like a little bit
out there to the fringe,
and as we started digging into the pages,
we did realize that there were moments,
we were like, this is not
how a native English speaker
would say this thing.
There would be these
really funny long prose,
like the way you learn
to write in third grade.
Hilary Clinton is a terrible person,
therefore it is important
that we do not elect her president,
ergo,
we must all vote for Donald Trump, right?
And so the sort of extra,
nobody running a Texas
secessionist page talks like that.
(laughing)
Not to stereotype, but let's be honest.